Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
AT A SEXUALLY CHARGED
PHOTO SHOOT,
ELYSE AND ADRIANNE
ENTERTAINED VISITORS.
Adrianne: MAMA!
Tyra: ELYSE'S EATING HABITS
SPARKED CONTROVERSY
IN THE HOUSE.
Robin: WHY ARE YOU
WORRYING ABOUT FOOD?
YOU'RE NOT GONNA EAT.
Elyse: SHE'S DECIDED,
ELYSE DOESN'T EAT.
Adrianne: AND, LIKE, SHE'S,
LIKE, SO... SHE'S A TOOTHPICK.
Elyse: I'VE NEVER HAD
AN EATING PROBLEM.
Adrianne: SHE'S KILLING HERSELF.
Tyra: AND GISELLE'S
LACK OF CONFIDENCE...
Giselle: I MEAN, IF IT
REALLY SUCKS, JUST TELL ME.
Tyra: GETS HER SENT PACKING.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: EVEN THOUGH GISELLE
COULD BE ANNOYING SOMETIMES,
WHEN SHE WASN'T,
SHE WAS ACTUALLY COOL.
Elyse: BEING IN
THE FINAL TWO GIRLS,
I WAS WITH GISELLE
AT THE ELIMINATION,
IT'S INCREDIBLY STRESSFUL,
AND I THINK I WANT THE PRIZE
A LITTLE BIT MORE NOW
THAN I DID AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE COMPETITION.
Adrianne: OH, MY GOD, IF THEY
MOVE PEOPLE IN HERE, WHO'S GONNA
WANT TO SLEEP ON THE BED
THAT GET FARTED ON CONSTANTLY?
Shannon: WHY DIDN'T YOU
START OFF YOUR DAY
WITH READING THE WORD?
Robin: "LORD,
BLESS ME AND THEE,
ENLARGE MY TERRITORIES.
KEEP YOUR HAND UPON ME."
MISS SHANNON'S 18 YEARS OLD.
SHE'S STILL A VIRGIN,
BELIEVES IN THE LORD.
MISS KESSE, MYSELF
AND MISS SHANNON,
WE JUST PRAY EVERY DAY THAT
WE'RE THE LAST THREE STANDING.
Elyse: THE SEPARATION
BETWEEN THE TWO ROOMS HAS A LOT
TO DO WITH RELIGION.
THE HOUSE HAS BEEN DIVIDED
INTO US AND THEM.
I WAS LAUGHING
AT YOUR UGLY TITS.
Adrianne: I HAVE
BEAUTIFUL TITS.
THE TOKYO SIDE IS MORE RAUCOUS
AND NUDE.
Adrianne: ALMOST EVERYONE
THAT LOOKS AT MY BOOBS,
THEY'RE LIKE, "GOD, THEY'RE
SO JIGGLY AND BEAUTIFUL."
- Both: (laughing)
- Adrianne: KESSE!
HOW ABOUT WE CLEAN UP
OUR LANGUAGE?
HAVE A SEAT.
WOULD YOU JUST GO
TO THE SEX SHOP
FOR, LIKE, TWO SECONDS?
Kesse: GIRL, I'VE BEEN
TO SEX SHOPS BEFORE.
Adrianne: MISS KESSE'S DOWN!
Elyse: KESSE'S HILARIOUS.
SHE'S PART OF THE HOLY ROOM,
AND SHE'S PART
OF THE BIBLE TIME.
AND YET, I THINK SHE'S SO FUNNY.
AND I THINK SHE'S COMING OUT
OF HER SHELL A LOT MORE.
Kesse: WE RECEIVED TYRA MAIL
THAT WE WERE GOING TO WILHELMINA
THE NEXT MORNING.
Elyse: WILHELMINA
IS THE AGENCY THAT WE WILL
RECEIVE A CONTRACT FROM
IF WE WIN THE CONTEST.
Adrianne: I WAS VERY,
VERY EXCITED
BECAUSE MY WHOLE LIFE
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO FIND A WAY
TO GO TO NEW YORK
TO GO TO A MODELING AGENCY.
Pink: HEY, EVERYBODY.
HAVE A SEAT AROUND HERE.
MY NAME'S PINK,
I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE WOMEN'S DIVISION HERE
AT WILHELMINA.
I BOOK MODELS.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT ROUGHLY 2,000
TO 3,000 GIRLS GOING UP
FOR ONE OR TWO POSITIONS.
SO YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF,
DO YOU HAVE WHAT IT TAKES?
ON A DAY
THAT YOU'RE NOT WORKING,
YOU'RE DOING WHAT'S CALLED
A "GO SEE."
LET'S SAY YOU'RE NEW IN TOWN.
SO I HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE CLIENTS GET TO KNOW YOU.
WHAT YOU DO IN THAT MINUTE
AND A HALF OF YOUR GO SEE
IS GONNA DETERMINE WHETHER
YOU GET THAT JOB OR NOT.
YOU HAVE TO IMPRESS
UPON THAT CLIENT
THAT YOU'RE THE GIRL.
IF YOU CAN GET
FOUR OR FIVE CLIENTS
THAT ARE BOOKING YOU
ONCE A MONTH,
YOU MAKE $20,000 TO $25,000
A MONTH.
Adrianne: WHEW.
THAT'S SOME MONEY.
Elyse: PINK ALSO GAVE
EACH OF US CRITICISMS
AND A LITTLE HELP ALONG THE WAY.
AND WE MADE OUR FIRST PORTFOLIO.
Pink: THIS IS AMAZING.
LIKE, I COULD... I COULD SEND
YOU OUT WITH THIS PICTURE
RIGHT NOW.
ARE THEY GONNA SEE THIS HAIRCUT?
OR ARE THEY GONNA SEE YOUR HAIR
PULLED BACK TO A PONYTAIL,
'CAUSE IT'S REALLY EASY
TO PUT IT TOGETHER THAT WAY?
PEOPLE LOVE ACCENTS
IN THIS BUSINESS, TOO, SO DON'T
FEEL BAD IF YOU HAVE AN ACCENT
FROM WHEREVER YOU COME FROM.
Robin: YOU GONNA HAVE
PEOPLE TELLING YOU, YOU KNOW,
YOU NEED TO DO THIS.
YOU DON'T LOOK RIGHT IN THIS.
YOU'RE TOO THIS.
YOU'RE NOT ENOUGH OF THIS.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE CONFIDENCE,
YOU'RE GONNA CRACK.
Pink: THIS SHOT IS GORGEOUS.
YOUR BODY'S
IN REALLY GOOD SHAPE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S
VERY FLATTERING.
THIS ONE IS MORE FLATTERING
TOWARDS YOUR BODY.
DON'T BE AFRAID
TO LET SOME OF THAT PERSONALITY
SHINE THROUGH.
Kesse: I'M KINDA SHY
AT TIMES, QUIET SOMETIMES,
BUT I'M WORKING ON IT.
I'M TRYING TO BE MORE OPEN.
Pink: I HOPE YOU GUYS
LEARNED SOMETHING TODAY.
'CAUSE TODAY WE'RE GONNA
SEND YOU OFF TO PARIS.
I HOPE YOU LISTENED
TO WHAT I HAD TO SAY.
Shannon: ARE YOU SERIOUS?
Robin: OH, MY WORD!
Adrianne: HELL, YEAH, I CRIED.
I WAS GOING TO PARIS.
I'VE NEVER LEFT THE COUNTRY.
Shannon: I'M SO EXCITED,
I'M TRYING TO TAKE IT ALL IN.
Kesse: I WAS SURPRISED
WHEN HE SAID
WE WERE GOING TO PARIS TODAY.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT, YOU KNOW?
Robin: JUST TO GET
TO PARIS...
Pink: THE ONE THING
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
GOING TO PARIS, I MEAN,
THE INTELLIGENT MODEL TRAVELER
PACKS ONE BAG.
YOU NEED TO NARROW IT DOWN
TO ONE CARRY-ON.
Elyse: HOW MANY PAIRS
OF UNDERWEAR ARE YOU BRINGING?
Adrianne: WE ONLY HAD
THREE HOURS
FROM THE TIME WE GOT HOME
TO PACK OUR BAGS
AND GET THE HELL OUT
AND GO TO THE AIRPORT.
Elyse: ROBIN IS GONNA HAVE
A PRETTY BIG PROBLEM
WITH THE ONE-BAG-PER-GIRL RULE.
I SAW HER IN HER ROOM
DESPERATELY TRY TO STUFF
STUFF INTO HER SUITCASE.
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
IT'S GOING TOO WELL.
Robin: I'M SO SLEEPY,
LET'S TAKE A REST.
Shannon: CALL YOUR BOYFRIEND,
SOMETHING I DON'T HAVE YET.
I'VE NEVER HAD
A SERIOUS BOYFRIEND.
NEVER REALLY HAD A BOYFRIEND,
SO I'M JUST LIKE,
PLEASE, LORD,
SEND ME SOMEBODY SOMETIME.
Elyse: I JUST WANTED
TO CHECK IN AND TELL YOU
I MIGHT NOT GET A CHANCE
TO USE THE PHONE
IN THE COMING DAYS.
Adrianne: I LOVE YOU.
WISH ME LUCK, MAN.
Robin: I LOVE YOU,
SWEETHEART.
- Man: I love you, too.
- Robin: OKAY.
- Man: Bye.
- Robin: BYE.
Shannon: I LOVE YOU, BRAD.
I HUNG UP THIS GUY
NAMED BRAD PINKERT.
I SAW HIM IN, LIKE,
THIS MAGAZINE, AND WHAT CAUGHT
MY EYE WAS THAT
HIS FAVORITE BOOK WAS THE BIBLE.
HE LOOKS MIGHTY FINE TO ME.
WHEREVER YOU ARE, BOY,
I'M GONNA COME FIND YOU.
HERE WE GO, LADIES.
PARIS!
Adrianne: THIS IS DEFINITELY
THE BEST DAY OF MY LIFE.
♪♪♪
Elyse: I WAS REALLY TIRED.
I THINK ALL OF US WERE.
"WELCOME TO PARIS.
HERE IS THE ADDRESS
OF YOUR HOTEL.
IT'S LOCATED
ON 28 RUE DE L'ARC DE TRIOMPHE.
TELL YOUR DRIVER
TO TAKE YOU THERE.
NO, YOUR DRIVER
DOESN'T SPEAK ENGLISH."
- Man: (speaks French)
- Robin: I'M GONNA HOLD THIS.
ME KEEPY-THIS-AY.
Shannon: SIR,
VINGT-HUIT RUE DE L'ARC.
- Man: BIEN. TRèS BIEN.
- Shannon: OUI, BIEN.
Kesse: WELL, I USED TO SAY
I'M GONNA MOVE TO PARIS.
I'M GONNA LIVE IN PARIS.
I WANT TO GET AWAY FROM JUST
THE WHOLE ENVIRONMENT
OF BEING IN ARKANSAS.
Adrianne: THE DRIVER
BROUGHT US TO PARIS,
AND I WAS JUST AWESTRUCK.
WHAT IS THAT THING
ON THE TOWER?
LOOK AT ALL THESE FOREIGN CARS.
Robin: I EXPECTED TO SEE
PEOPLE ON BOATS
WITH THE VIOLINS.
I DIDN'T REALIZE IT WAS,
LIKE, SO BEAUTIFUL.
Elyse: I DIDN'T REALLY
LIKE PARIS.
MY UNCLE ACTUALLY LIVES HERE,
AND SO I VISITED
WHEN I WAS ABOUT 15.
Adrianne: THAT BUILDING
LOOKS FREAKIN' AWESOME.
Man: C'EST LA LOUVRE.
Shannon: OUI.
Adrianne: IT'S SO BEAUTIFUL.
Shannon: LA LOUVRE.
LOOK HOW BEAUTIFUL
THAT BUILDING IS.
I FORGET WHAT IT IS EXACTLY.
Adrianne: THIS PLACE IS,
LIKE, THE MOST BEAUTIFUL PLACE
IN THE WORLD.
NEW YORK WAS
THE MOST BEAUTIFUL PLACE
IN THE WORLD LAST WEEK,
BUT THIS WEEK IT'S PARIS.
Adrianne: MY IMPRESSION
OF THE HOTEL
WHEN I FIRST PULLED UP
ALONGSIDE WAS, LIKE,
A SUPER-DUPER AUTHENTIC, LIKE,
HOLE-IN-THE-WALL TYPE OF, LIKE,
FRENCH HOTEL.
- Joseph: WELCOME TO PARIS.
- Shannon: THANK YOU.
Joseph: I'M JOSEPH,
THE OWNER OF THE HOTEL.
AND I WILL HOPE YOU WILL ENJOY
YOUR STAY IN PARIS.
- Adrianne: WELL, THANK YOU.
- Joseph: OKAY, TAKE YOUR KEY.
Robin: WE GET INTO THE LOBBY,
AND THEY TELL US THAT WE HAVE TO
WALK OUR BAGS UP TO OUR ROOM.
Kesse: YOU OKAY?
Shannon: YEAH.
Kesse: BUT TRYING TO,
YOU KNOW,
PULL THAT HUGE SUITCASE
WAS LIKE, YOU KNOW, GOSH,
I THOUGHT I WAS JUST GONNA FALL
ALL THE WAY DOWN THE STAIRS.
Robin: WHEN WE WALKED IN
IT WAS JUST LIKE, YOU KNOW,
OH, MY GOODNESS.
Shannon: THREE BEDS.
Elyse: YOU GUYS WANNA DRAW
STRAWS FOR WHO'S ON THE FLOOR?
Shannon: WE GOT TYRA MAIL.
"HI, GIRLS, THIS IS WHERE
YOU'LL BE LIVING
WHILE YOU'RE IN PARIS.
FIND A PLACE TO PUT YOUR THINGS
AND SELECT A BED."
Shannon: WHERE'S OUR BATHROOM?
Elyse: IT'S RIGHT HERE.
THERE WERE THREE BEDS.
NO PHONE, NO TV
AND ONE BATHROOM
AND VERY LITTLE SPACE.
Robin: DOES ANYBODY WANT
TO SLEEP IN THE SLEEPING BAG?
Elyse: NOT PARTICULARLY.
Adrianne: FIVE PEOPLE
IN AN EXTREMELY SQUASHED ROOM,
LIVING WITH A DIVA THAT TAKES
A VERY LONG TIME IN THERE.
Shannon: WE ARE ALL LIVING
IN THIS SMALL ROOM TOGETHER.
SOMETHING'S GONNA HAPPEN.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: I THINK EVERYBODY,
WHEN THEY SAW THE ROOM,
WAS VERY DEPRESSED.
Elyse: YOU GUYS
WANNA DRAW STRAWS
FOR WHO'S ON THE FLOOR?
Elyse: I IMMEDIATELY SAW
GIRLS EDGING TOWARD THE BEDS.
SO I INSISTED THAT
WE DRAW NAMES.
OKAY, SO THE FIRST THREE NAMES
WILL BE FOR THE THREE BEDS.
Shannon: KESSE, YOU DRAW.
- Robin: FOR THE FOUR BEDS.
- Kesse: NOT THE SLEEPING BAG.
- Adrianne: THE AIR BED.
- Kesse: YEAH.
MOI.
Shannon: YEAH--
OH, IT WAS YOU.
Adrianne: SHANNON. ELYSE.
Kesse: ADRIANNE.
Adrianne: HOLY CRAP.
Elyse: I THOUGHT IT WAS
PRETTY FUNNY THAT ROBIN
GOT THE AIR MATTRESS.
Adrianne: ROBIN'S GOTTA
SLEEP ON THE FLOOR.
Robin: MISS KESSE DID OFFER
TO SHARE HER BED WITH ME,
BUT I MEAN, I'M NOT, YOU KNOW,
SO SPECIAL WHERE I CAN'T SLEEP
ON THE AIR MATTRESS.
♪♪♪
Elyse: AFTER WE SETTLED
INTO OUR ROOM,
WE JUST WANTED
TO HANG OUT AND TOOL AROUND
AND CHECK OUT THE SIGHTS.
Robin: YOU LOOK
AT THESE BUILDINGS
AND YOU LOOK AT THESE FIXTURES,
AND YOU'RE LIKE, YOU KNOW,
OH, MY GOODNESS.
Adrianne: YOU GUYS,
I LOVE FRENCH CULTURE.
Man: WHERE IS YOUR HUSBAND?
Robin: I DON'T HAVE
A HUSBAND, UNFORTUNATELY.
Man: OH, THAT'S OKAY.
YOU CAN STAY IN PARIS WITH ME.
Shannon: THANKS.
THAT GUY WAS ALL OVER MY FACE.
Shannon: (shudders)
♪♪♪
Kesse: "TONIGHT I WILL
JOIN YOU FOR DINNER.
BE READY IN THE LOBBY
AT 7 P.M. TYRA."
Adrianne: I'VE BEEN WEARING
THE SAME UNDERWEAR
FOR ALMOST 48 HOURS.
IT'S JUST DISGUSTING.
WHO'S GONNA CHANGE?
THAT'S WHAT I'M WEARING.
Shannon: A LITTLE, YOU KNOW,
NOT SHOWERED, A LITTLE, LIKE,
YOU KNOW, SWEATY,
BUT WE JUST TRIED TO, LIKE,
WASH OFF A LITTLE BIT,
GET A CHANGE OF CLOTHES.
Adrianne: YOU GUYS,
I'VE NEVER FELT THIS ICKY
IN MY ENTIRE LIFE.
Robin: I AIN'T GOT
NO CLOTHES ON, MAN.
Adrianne: ALL THE OTHER GIRLS
WERE VERY UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH BEING NUDE
AROUND EACH OTHER.
I MEAN, I JUST OUTRIGHT
TOLD THEM, I'M SORRY,
WHEN I HAVE TO CHANGE,
I'M GOING TO.
I DON'T CARE WHERE IT IS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A LESBIAN
TO CHANGE IN FRONT
OF YOUR FRIEND, YOU KNOW?
- Elyse: (speaks French)
- Adrianne: HOW DO YOU SAY,
"ADRIANNE HAS
ENORMOUS CHA-CHAS?"
- Elyse: (speaks French)
- Adrianne: ELYSE, HOW BAD
DOES YOUR COOCH SMELL,
HOW DO YOU SAY THAT?
- Elyse: (speaks French)
- Robin: WHEN ADRIANNE SAYS
THINGS THAT ARE INAPPROPRIATE,
I MIGHT LOOK AT HER IN A WAY
THAT THE TEACHER WOULD LOOK
AT YOU IF YOU DID SOMETHING
INAPPROPRIATE IN CLASS.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR THAT.
I DON'T SPEAK LIKE THAT.
I DON'T ACT LIKE THAT.
Elyse: DO YOU GET IN TROUBLE
FOR THE THINGS YOU SAY?
I TRY TO AVOID
DELIBERATELY PISSING OFF ROBIN,
BUT ADRIANNE DEFINITELY DOES
DELIBERATELY DO IT,
AND THAT'S GREAT
FOR ME TO WATCH.
♪♪♪
Tyra: BONJOUR. BONJOUR.
All: BONJOUR.
Tyra: HOW ARE YOU?
Elyse: TYRA SHOWED UP
AT THE FRENCH RESTAURANT,
AND SHE TOLD US A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HER EXPERIENCE IN PARIS.
Tyra: THIS CITY IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE SUCCESS OF MY CAREER.
I WANTED TO PERSONALLY
INTRODUCE THE GIRLS TO THE CITY
WHERE I STARTED MY CAREER.
BUT IT TOOK A SCOUT FROM PARIS
BY THE NAME OF VERONIQUE
WHO CAME TO LOS ANGELES
AND SAID, "I THINK YOU CAN BE
A STAR, AND I WANT YOU TO COME
TO PARIS."
AND THAT'S WHY IT WAS
SO IMPORTANT FOR ME
TO HAVE YOU GUYS COME HERE.
I INSISTED THAT THIS BE A PART
OF YOUR EXPERIENCE.
AND IF YOU GUYS ARE MAD
AT YOUR APARTMENT,
THAT WAS MY IDEA,
BECAUSE A MODEL'S APARTMENTS
ARE CRAMPED AND TIGHT,
BUT I HAVE, LIKE,
BITTERSWEET MEMORIES OF PARIS.
BEING 17,
RIGHT OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL,
GETTING ON A PLANE FOR
THE FIRST TIME BY MYSELF,
AND I HUGGED MY MOM AND MY DAD,
AND THEY'RE LIKE,
"ARE YOU OKAY?"
AND I'M LIKE, "YEAH,"
AND THEN I TURNED AND I WAS...
I JUST BOO-HOOED,
MY MOM DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT MARKET.
I WANT YOU GUYS,
WHOEVER THIS WINNER IS,
TO WORK THE WORLD.
Kesse: I JUST WANT TO BE OUT
ON MY OWN FOR AWHILE,
AND EXPERIENCE, YOU KNOW,
THE REAL WORLD BY MYSELF.
I MEAN, I WANT THIS REALLY BAD.
"TOMORROW MORNING
WILL BE YOUR FIRST..." WHAT?
"PARISIAN PHOTO SHOOT.
BE READY AT 7:30 A.M.
IN THE LOBBY."
Elyse: EVERYONE WAS
SO READY TO GO TO SLEEP.
Adrianne: I CAN'T MOVE.
EXHAUSTION.
Robin: RIGHT,
LET MAMA WASH HER FACE.
Adrianne: ROBIN HAS TO
SLEEP ON THE FLOOR--
MISS PAGEANTRY.
(blow dryer running)
Adrianne: I THINK
SHE TOOK IT OUT ON US,
BECAUSE SHE WAS UP VERY LATE
BLOW DRYING HER HAIR,
SMASHING ABOUT.
Robin: EVERY GIRL
WASHED THEIR HAIR,
AND I HAD TO BLOW DRY MINE.
(blow dryer running)
Elyse: I THINK
THAT ROBIN HERSELF
DOESN'T HAVE A VERY GOOD IDEA
OF WHAT A CHRISTIAN IS.
(blow dryer running)
♪♪♪
Shannon: TODAY, UM,
A PHOTO SHOOT IN PARIS.
IT WAS OUR FIRST
PARISIAN PHOTO SHOOT.
Kesse: OH, MY GOSH,
THERE'S NOTHING LIKE IT.
Adrianne: THIS IS
INSANELY BEAUTIFUL.
Kesse: EIFFEL TOWER.
OH, IT'S SO BEAUTIFUL.
LOOKIN' AT IT,
IT IS JUST LIKE, "WOW."
Iderlin: SO
LET'S TRY THIS ONE ON NOW
AND SEE IF THIS ONE WORKS.
Kesse: OUR FITTING WAS BRAS--
BRAS AND UNDERWEAR--SO IT WAS
A PHOTO SHOOT FOR WONDERBRA.
Robin: THE PHOTO SHOOTS
ARE GETTING MORE
AND MORE INTERESTING,
FOR LACK OF BETTER WORDS.
Elyse: CAN WE SEE YOUR BRA?
Shannon: YOU CAN SEE MY BRA,
BUT ANYTHING ELSE, YOU AIN'T...
Adrianne: AH, HA HA HA.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IT IS
THAT SHANNON'S HOLDING INSIDE.
I THINK SHE'S JUST SO CRAZY
BECAUSE SHE'S NEVER
DONE ANYTHING--
SHE'S NEVER TOUCHED HERSELF.
SHE'S NEVER WATCHED A PORN.
SHE'S NEVER DONE ANYTHING.
Shannon: I THINK
THAT MY UNCOVERED BODY
IS FOR ONE PERSON ONLY,
THAT'S MY HUSBAND.
SO I DON'T KNOW.
I JUST DON'T THINK
IT'S FOR THE WORLD TO SEE.
NO ONE IN THE HOUSE IS--
EVERYONE IN THE HOUSE--
WELL, I MEAN, EVERYONE'S NOT
AS COMFORTABLE WALKING AROUND
IN THONG UNDERWEAR
LIKE YOU ARE.
Adrianne: HOW ARE YOU GUYS
GONNA BE MODELS?
Jay: HELLO. DO YOU THINK
IT'S OKAY TO MASTURBATE?
WE ALREADY
HAD THIS CONVERSATION,
BUT I WANNA SEE
WHAT YOUR OPINION IS.
Shannon: I'VE NEVER DONE IT
BEFORE, BUT I DON'T KNOW.
I KNEW A GUY, WHAT HE DID,
BUT I--
Jay: YEAH, BUT WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT MEN RIGHT NOW.
Shannon: I DIDN'T KNOW WE
COULD DO IT, LIKE, TO OURSELVES.
Robin: HI.
Michel: HI, GIRLS.
MY NAME IS MICHEL HADDI,
NICE TO MEET YOU LADIES.
Elyse: NICE TO MEET YOU, TOO.
Michel: I HOPE THAT TODAY
YOU'RE READY TO RUMBLE.
I HOPE, BE GOOD, BE BAD,
BE AS BAD AS YOU CAN BE.
ALL RIGHT?
Elyse: WE ALL GOT IN
BRAS AND UNDERWEAR
AND GOT OUR MAKEUP
AND HAIR DONE.
AND THEN THE SURPRISE
WAS THAT THERE WOULD BE
A MALE MODEL POSING WITH US.
Shannon: OH, MY WORD!
I WALKED IN THE FIRST ROOM,
I TURN AROUND, AND I SEE THIS
REALLY MUSCULAR GUY IN BOXERS.
Man: HOW YOU DOING?
- Shannon: GOOD.
- Man: I'M BRAD.
- Shannon: SHANNON.
- Brad: NICE TO MEET YOU.
Shannon: OH, MY WORD!
YOU GUYS, NO!
IT WAS BRAD PINKERT,
THE GUY I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS WHOLE TRIP.
I HAD A POSTER OF HIM
IN MY ROOM.
ARE YOU, LIKE, THE MODEL?
Brad: I BELIEVE SO, YES.
Shannon: YOU GUYS GOTTA BE...
OH, MY GOSH,
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER TO SMILE,
WHETHER TO GET RED, WHETHER TO,
LIKE, TURN AROUND AND LEAVE.
Michel: OKAY,
LET'S WORK, GUYS.
LET'S DO SOME PHOTOGRAPH.
THAT'S IT.
ENJOY IT.
Shannon: I WAS GRABBING HIM
OR SOMETHING, LIKE,
HE HAD TO PUT
HIS ARMS AROUND ME,
AND I WAS LIKE,
"I'VE NEVER BEEN
IN THIS POSITION BEFORE."
Michel: OKAY, BITE HIM.
BITE--GO FOR IT.
VERY GOOD, LET'S SEE IT.
AND YOU CAN BE CLOSER.
NOTHING IS GOING TO HAPPEN
TO YOU, I PROMISE.
Shannon: AND HE'S GOT
SOME MUSCLES, MAN!
HE'S GOT SOME MUSCLES.
Michel: THAT'S VERY GOOD.
Shannon: (giggles)
OH, THIS IS LOVELY.
Michel: NO, NO, IT'S ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S IT.
SHANNON IS JUST A BIT LOST,
BUT SHE'S GOT
A VERY BEAUTIFUL FACE.
Brad: I HOPE I WAS
EVERYTHING SHE THOUGHT
I WAS GOING TO BE.
Shannon: I'LL SEE YOU LATER.
Brad: ALL RIGHT, DEFINITELY.
HAVE FUN.
Michel: HEAD TO HEAD,
STRAIGHT ON.
I WANT TWO FACES
CLOSE TO EACH OTHER, RIGHT?
VERY GOOD,
STAY LIKE YOU ARE.
THAT'S VERY GOOD,
DON'T MOVE.
STAY LIKE YOU ARE.
VERY GOOD.
THAT'S GOOD.
Elyse: POSING WITH BRAD
WAS LIKE POSING WITH A STATUE.
I WASN'T UNCOMFORTABLE AT ALL.
Michel: SHE'S FABULOUS.
YEAH, ELYSE IS LIKE...
SHE'S LIKE A LITTLE FAWN,
YOU KNOW, COMING OUT
OF A WALT DISNEY MOVIE.
YOU HAVE TO TALK THE TALK
AND WALK THE WALK.
YOUR LEGS HAS TO BE STRONG.
GO SHOW ME,
SHOW ME LONG LEGS, LONG.
Kesse: YOU KNOW, I WAS TRYING
TO DO MY BEST TO,
YOU KNOW, WHATEVER,
BUT I DIDN'T THINK I WAS
DOING IT HOW HE WANTED IT.
Michel: YOUR HAIR THERE.
VERY GOOD.
YOU HAVE TO MOVE, OKAY? NOW.
Michel: HOME FREE, THAT'S IT.
SHE'S TOO SCARED
THAT'S THE PROBLEM,
AND SHE'S NOT CONFIDENT.
Adrianne: DON'T YOU LOVE
DOING THAT?
MY BOOBS.
Iderlin: THANK YOU.
Michel: STAY LIKE YOU ARE.
VERY GOOD.
Adrianne: WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE ON FIRE, AND I WAS.
Michel: VERY GOOD,
STAY LIKE YOU ARE.
SHE'S GOT IT,
AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
- Brad: HI, NICE TO MEET YOU.
- Robin: NICE TO MEET YOU, TOO.
Michel: WRAP YOUR HANDS
AROUND HER.
TURN YOUR BODY A BIT MORE,
A BIT MORE, A BIT MORE.
Robin: I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT THE SETUP WAS WITH THE GUY.
I WAS A LITTLE, YOU KNOW,
UNCOMFORTABLE AT FIRST
NOT KNOWING THE SETTING
OF THE SCENE OR WHATEVER.
Michel: JUST RELAX.
Robin: YOU KNOW, ONCE I,
LIKE I SAID, SAID MY PRAYER
AND CLEARED MY MIND, YOU KNOW,
SOME THINGS YOU DON'T LIKE,
BUT YOU DO BECAUSE OF THE JOB.
Michel: ROBIN IS
A FABULOUS GIRL,
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
SHE DOESN'T TRUST HER OWN BODY.
Adrianne: WERE YOU
UNCOMFORTABLE, THOUGH, SHANNON?
NO, BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN DREAMING
OVER THAT GUY FOR SO LONG.
Shannon: NO.
Adrianne: YES, YOU HAVE.
Shannon: I WAS A LITTLE BIT
NERVOUS, BECAUSE I'VE NEVER
HAD A PHOTO SHOOT WITH A GUY,
ESPECIALLY ONE THAT
I'VE BEEN WANTING TO MEET.
AND THE FIRST TIME WE MEET
EACH OTHER, WE'RE, LIKE,
IN OUR, LIKE, UNDERWEAR.
Adrianne: (speaking French)
- Shannon: (speaking French)
- (knock on door)
Adrianne: HELLO.
Shannon: OH!
- Kesse: HEY, BRAD.
- Brad: HOW'S EVERYBODY FEEL?
HOW'D IT GO?
- Adrianne: ALL RIGHT.
- Shannon: GOOD.
Brad: IT WENT OKAY
WITH ME, TOO.
YOU GUYS WANNA GO OUT
TO DINNER LATER?
Shannon: YEAH!
WE'RE ALWAYS HUNGRY.
Brad: I'M NOT REALLY SURE,
BUT I KNOW WE'LL HAVE SOME FUN.
ALL RIGHT,
I'LL SEE YOU GUYS.
- Kesse: THANKS, BRAD.
- Adrianne: BYE.
- Elyse: BYE, BRAD.
Shannon: (squeals)
I'VE BEEN ON A FEW DATES
BUT NOT LIKE "DATE" DATES.
YEAH, I GET NERVOUS.
WE'RE GOIN' OUT TO DINNER.
WHOO!
Elyse: IT'S GONNA BE SO FUN.
Shannon: I DON'T HAVE
ANY CLOTHES. NO!
♪♪♪
Elyse: WHEN WE GOT BACK
TO THE APARTMENT,
WE HAD TO CHANGE OUR CLOTHES
REALLY QUICKLY.
AND WE WENT TO DINNER WITH BRAD.
Robin: I'LL BET
YOU'RE NERVOUS.
Brad: NO, I'M FINE.
Robin: SO WHAT DID THEY
TELL YOU ABOUT MISS SHANNON?
Brad: THEY JUST SAID,
"SOMEBODY HAS A CRUSH ON YOU"
OR "SOMEBODY HAS YOUR PICTURE
AND KNOWS OF YOU."
AND I WAS FLATTERED.
Robin: SO WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF MISS SHANNON?
Shannon: I'M SITTING
RIGHT HERE.
Brad: I TOLD 'EM
I WAS STUNNED.
Robin: WELL, I WAS JUST
TRYING TO GET MISS SHANNON
TO TALK MORE, BUT YOU KNOW,
SHE DOESN'T' REALLY TALK
A WHOLE LOT AROUND GUYS.
Brad: DID WE HAVE FUN TODAY?
Elyse: DID YOU?
Brad: OH, I HAD FUN.
YOU KNOW, IT WAS TIRING.
BUT A MAN'S GOTTA DO
WHAT A MAN'S GOTTA DO, I GUESS.
Robin: WHAT'S
YOUR FAVORITE BOOK?
Brad: FAVORITE BOOK?
ONE OF THEM'S THE BIBLE.
Adrianne: WHAT'S ANOTHER ONE?
Brad: ANOTHER BOOK?
Shannon: THERE'S
NO CHICKEN ON HERE.
Brad: I DON'T READ TOO MUCH.
Adrianne: I TOLD SHANNON--
SHE THOUGHT,
"OH, THIS GUY LIKES THE BIBLE.
HE'S GONNA BE SO NICE."
WELL, IN HIS LITTLE, LIKE,
SPREAD SHEET IN "COSMO GIRL!,"
IT SAID THAT HIS FAVORITE MOVIE
WAS "BOOGIE NIGHTS."
Robin: YOU JUST, YOU KNOW,
GO OUT AND HAVE FUN, WHATEVER.
JUST GO.
Shannon: OKAY, NO.
I DON'T WANNA GO BY MYSELF.
Adrianne: WELL,
BRAD'S GONNA BE THERE.
Robin: GIRL, COME ON.
YEAH, BRAD WILL SHOW YOU
THE CITY FOR A LITTLE WHILE.
Elyse: I THINK
SHANNON SUBMITTED TO PRESSURES
FROM ROBIN.
ROBIN SAID
THAT IT WOULDN'T COMPLY
WITH ETIQUETTE IF SHANNON
DIDN'T GO OUT ON A DATE
WITH BRAD AFTER DINNER.
Robin: SHE HAD HIS PICTURE
ON HER CANOPY.
THAT'S LIKE A NICE LITTLE WAY
OF SAYING THANK YOU.
Woman: (singing in French)
Shannon: AT TIMES,
I ENJOY BEING SINGLE,
'CAUSE I'VE BEEN SINGLE
FOR I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG.
BUT DEEP DOWN I THINK THAT I
WOULD ENJOY HAVING A BOYFRIEND
JUST BECAUSE I'M A ROMANTIC.
Woman: (singing in French)
Shannon: I'M SO EMBARRASSED.
Elyse: WHY?
Kesse: WHAT HAPPENED?
Shannon: WELL, I'M GONNA TELL
Y'ALL THE ENDING.
I WAS LEAVING,
AND YOU KNOW HOW
SOMETIMES YOU KISS ONCE,
SOMETIMES WOMEN GIVE TWO?
WELL, I GAVE HIM ONE
AND HE WAS LIKE,
"NOW YOU GOTTA GIVE TWO."
Robin: SO WE GOTTA
DRESS TO IMPRESS TOMORROW
WITH YOUR PORTFOLIO.
Shannon: "BE READY
TOMORROW MORNING AT 9:00 A.M.--
9 IN THE MORNING.
BE DRESSED TO IMPRESS
ALONG WITH YOUR PORTFOLIO.
MAKE THE MOST OF THE DAY,
BECAUSE TOMORROW NIGHT,
ONE OF YOU
WILL HAVE TO GO HOME."
Kesse: I LOVE THEM
LIKE WE'VE BEEN FRIENDS FOREVER.
AND IT'S GETTING HARDER,
YOU KNOW,
KNOWING THAT SOMEBODY'S LEAVING.
Adrianne: WELL,
ALL I'VE GOT TO SAY IS
IF I'M GONNA BE ELIMINATED,
I'D RATHER BE ELIMINATED
IN PARIS.
Robin: TODAY
WE'RE GOING TO DO GO SEES.
AND YOU GO SEE A CLIENT,
AND THEY GIVE YOU FEEDBACK
ON WHETHER OR NOT THEY LIKE YOU.
Shannon: I AM READY
AND EXCITED.
EVEN THOUGH IT COULD BE
A PRETTY NERVE-RACKING DAY.
- Woman: HELLO.
- All: HI.
- Woman: HOW ARE YOU?
- Shannon: GOOD.
Marilyn: MY NAME'S MARILYN,
AND I'M THE HEAD OF THE AGENCY.
TO YOU, IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO START IN PARIS.
ALL TOP MODELS
HAVE STARTED HERE.
AS PART OF THE TEST,
WE'RE GOING TO DO GO SEES TODAY.
OKAY, NOW LET'S GO
AND SEE EMMA--
SHE'S IN THE OTHER ROOM--
AND GO IN TO MEET HER.
Emma: HELLO, I'M EMMA.
I LOOK AFTER THE NEW FACES
DIVISION AT MARILYN'S.
YOU'VE GOT FIVE GO AND SEES
THAT YOU'RE GONNA DO
THIS AFTERNOON
BETWEEN 2:00 AND 7:00.
EACH ONE'S GOT A DIFFERENT TIME.
SO ONE'S GONNA BE BETWEEN
2:00 AND 3:00,
ONE'S BETWEEN 3:00 AND 4:00.
YOU HAVE TO GET TO ALL OF THEM,
AND YOU ALSO HAVE TO GO ALONE.
NOW I'M GONNA EXPLAIN TO YOU
HOW YOU'RE GONNA
GET AROUND PARIS
AND HOW YOU'RE GONNA GET BY
ON THE MéTRO.
WITHIN PARIS
ARE DIFFERENT AREAS,
WHICH ARE CALLED
ARRONDISSEMENTS.
EACH TIME, YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
A CHOICE WHETHER TO GO
NORTH OR SOUTH, EAST OR WEST.
NOW THERE MIGHT BE
RUE PARMENTIE,
THERE MIGHT BE AVENUE PARMENTIE,
THERE MIGHT BE PLACE PARMENTIE.
HAVE YOU GOT THE GRID KEY?
IT'S LIKE "G-4" OR "F-14."
SO IN YOUR MAPS,
YOU GO TO 18.
BLUE LINE'S NUMBER 2 LINE.
CONCONTE IS ON
THE NUMBER 1 LINE.
IT'S RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE.
IT'S WHEN YOU GET IN
THE MéTRO STATION,
YOU FOLLOW THAT DIRECTION.
OKAY, DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS?
(no audio)
Shannon: THAT IS JUST
SO MIND-BOGGLING
FOR ME TO COMPREHEND.
Emma: YOU'VE GOT FOUR HOURS
TO DO THIS,
AND YOU'VE GOT FIVE CASTINGS.
REMEMBER, THESE ARE CLIENTS.
THEY'RE WAITING TO SEE YOU.
YOU'VE GOT TO GET TO SEE THEM.
Robin: I DIDN'T WANT
TO TAKE THE MéTRO
AND COULDN'T SEE
WHY WE JUST COULDN'T TAKE A CAB.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, THAT'S, LIKE,
MY WAY OF LOOKING AT THINGS.
Emma: THE MéTRO IS A BIG "M"
OR MéTROPOLITAN.
GET INTO THE MéTRO
AND THEN GET GOING.
SPLIT UP AND JUST GET GOING.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: OKAY. SO...
THIS IS GOING TO BE A BITCH.
Kesse: I WAS CONFUSED,
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT I WAS DOING.
I WAS JUST TRYING TO HURRY UP.
(laughs)
♪♪♪
Elyse: I'M REALLY A BEGINNER.
Man: COOL.
Elyse: BUT I'VE BEEN TRYING
TO LEARN.
- Robin: YOU...
- Man #2: YOU.
Robin: COME WITH ME.
Man #2: UH-HUH.
Robin: AND HELP ME...
- Man #2: HELP YOU, YES.
- Robin: YES, FIND THESE.
Man #2: (whistles)
Robin: IT WAS HARD,
BUT I RESORTED BACK
TO MY PAGEANTRY SKILLS
AND REALIZED THAT EVEN IF
YOU DON'T KNOW FRENCH, SPANISH
OR MAYBE EVEN ENGLISH,
A SMILE IS UNIVERSAL.
AND I HAVE MONEY.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU SOME MONEY
AT THE END.
- Man #2: MONEY?
- Robin: YEAH.
- Man #2: ME?
- Robin: YEAH, YOU.
Man #2: TRèS BON. OUI. YES.
Robin: YEAH, YOU.
THAT'S HOW WE DO IT IN AMERICA.
Man #2: YES, YES.
♪♪♪
Woman: UH, HOW LONG
HAVE YOU BEEN MODELING?
Shannon: NOT VERY LONG.
I WAS ONLY FOCUSED, LIKE,
ON HIGH SCHOOL--
Woman: SHH.
WHO'S LISTENING TO US? NOBODY.
OKAY.
SO IT'S SOMETHING
YOU LOVE, FASHION?
Shannon: I LOVE IT,
I MEAN, EVEN IF...
IF I COULD DRAW, I WOULD BE,
LIKE, A FASHION DESIGNER
OR SOMETHING.
- Woman: OKAY.
- Shannon: I LOVE IT.
OKAY, MY LOVE,
THAT'S ENOUGH FOR ME TODAY.
I WILL REMEMBER YOU,
IT'S A PLEASURE.
Shannon: IT WAS SO NICE
MEETING YOU. THANK YOU.
Kesse: GOIN'
STRAIGHT DOWN, THEN?
Man: RIGHT THROUGH THERE.
Kesse: AND THEN GO DOWN.
Man: ELLE RECHERHCE LA MéTRO.
Woman: OUI, OUI,
MAIS S'IL VOUS PLAîT,
VISITEZ LE MAGASIN D'ABORD.
Kesse: LOOK,
IT MAKES YOU YOUNG, HUH?
Woman #2: YEAH.
Adrianne: I DON'T CARE.
I DON'T...
AAH!
Woman #2: YOU HAVE
THE LOTION HERE.
Kesse: OOH.
AND WHAT DOES THIS DO?
OKAY.
I MISSED THE THIRD LOCATION
BECAUSE I JUST LOST TRACK
OF TIME.
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT
THE OTHER GIRLS.
SO IF THEY FINISH EVERYTHING,
THEN THAT'S GOOD,
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THEY'RE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪♪♪
Elyse: BONJOUR.
PHILLIPE ECOUVIER,
S'IL VOUS PLAîT.
- Phillipe: BONJOUR.
- Elyse: BONJOUR.
JE M'APPELLE ELYSE SEWELL.
- Phillip: AH, OKAY.
- Kesse: HI. BONJOUR.
JE M'APPELLE KESSE.
Man: BUSY DAY?
Kesse: OH, IT'S BEEN BUSY,
BUT IT'S BEEN A RUSH, YOU KNOW?
Phillipe: CAN I SEE YOU WALKING?
Elyse: CARRYING MYSELF
MORE CONFIDENTLY
HAS BEEN A FORCED EFFORT,
AND I-I'VE DONE IT ON PURPOSE.
AND I THINK IT MIGHT BE WORKING.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: I AM SO LOST.
Woman: UH, I WOULD LIKE
TO TRY SOMETHING.
Robin: OKAY.
Woman: THANK YOU.
Adrianne: ENGLISH,
S'IL VOUS PLAîT?
NO?
DOES ANYONE SPEAK ENGLISH?
Adrianne: THIS MAN
WALKED UP TO ME IN THE STREET
AND, LIKE, BRUSHED MY LEG
LIKE THERE WAS
SOMETHING ON MY KNEE.
I THOUGHT,
OH, THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN
SOMETHING ON MY KNEE.
THEN HE PROCEEDED
TO TRY TO SHOVE HIS HAND
UP MY SKIRT TOWARDS MY CROTCH.
SO I WAS REALLY UPSET.
I MEAN, I WAS RIGHT THERE
BY THE AGENCY, BUT I--
I COULDN'T EVEN GO IN.
♪♪♪
Shannon: THE CHALLENGE WAS
TO GO AND SEE ALL FIVE AGENCIES
IN THE TIME THAT WAS ALLOTTED.
I MADE IT TO ALL THE AGENCIES
EVEN IF I WAS A FEW MINUTES LATE
ON ONE OR NOT,
BUT I STILL MADE IT.
Kesse: I'M HAVING A BLAST
IN PARIS, I AM.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: I WASN'T
AS FULLY CONFIDENT IN MYSELF.
I JUST...
I FEEL LIKE I CAN DO BETTER.
OH, MERCI, MERCI, MERCI.
Man: C'EST EXACT Là.
C'EST EXACT Là.
Adrianne: MERCI,
MERCI, MERCI.
Man: C'EST BON.
Adrianne: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I AM FROM CHICAGO, BUT--
- Woman: CHICAGO?
- Adrianne: YES.
YOU SAY IT LIKE ME. CHICAGO.
Woman: (laughs)
WHAT'S THE EYE COLOR,
BLUE-GRAY, SOMETHING?
Adrianne: BLUE-GRAY.
THEY CHANGE.
♪♪♪
Elyse: OUR LAST GO SEE,
UM, IT WAS AT A HOTEL,
AND I TOOK A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
TO TIGHTEN UP MY LIP
AND PUT ON SOME MORE MAKEUP
BEFORE I WENT IN.
WHEN I WALKED INTO THE ROOM,
I HAD NO IDEA
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
Robin: OKAY.
THIS IS THE LAST STOP.
THIS IS A LITTLE APPRECIATION
FROM ME TO YOU FOR HELPING ME.
- Man: MERCI.
- Robin: MERCI.
- Robin: MERCI BEAUCOUP.
SO... OH, THAT'S SWEET.
Kesse: THANK YOU.
Adrianne: I MISSED ONE TODAY.
Shannon: ALL RIGHT, YOU GUYS,
WE HAVE A LETTER.
Robin: OKAY.
Shannon: WE HAVE A LETTER.
UM, LET'S SEE.
"WELCOME TO YOUR FINAL GO SEE,
A MEETING WITH THE JUDGES.
PLEASE WAIT HERE
UNTIL FURTHER NOTICE."
Kesse: I DON'T KNOW WHO COULD BE
ELIMINATED, SERIOUSLY.
IT'S JUST... I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S GONNA BE SHOCKING,
WHOEVER IT IS.
YOU KNOW, FROM THIS POINT ON,
IT'S GONNA BE LIKE, DANG.
Adrianne: YOU GUYS,
I DON'T WANT TO GO HOME.
Robin: I DON'T GET NERVOUS
BECAUSE, UH,
NERVOUSNESS IS NOT A...
MY RELIGION TEACHES ME
THAT THAT'S NOT OF GOD.
Adrianne: YOU BETTER
PRETEND THAT YOU MISS ME
IF I LEAVE.
Elyse: YOU BETTER
BE CAREFUL, GIRL.
Adrianne: I'LL PRETEND
TO MISS YOU.
Tyra: BONSOIR, LADIES.
THIS WEEK YOU GUYS GOT A TASTE
OF THE JET-SET LIFE.
YOU LEARNED HOW TO PUT
TOGETHER YOUR PORTFOLIO,
YOU WENT ON GO SEES,
YOU DID A PHOTO SHOOT
IN FRONT OF THE EIFFEL TOWER,
WHICH I THOUGHT WAS FIERCE
'CAUSE I'VE NEVER
DONE THAT BEFORE.
THE WINNER WILL RECEIVE
A REVLON CONTRACT,
A CONTRACT
WITH WILHELMINA MODELS INC.
AND A FASHION SPREAD
IN "MARIE CLAIRE" MAGAZINE.
ONCE AGAIN,
WE HAVE OUR EXPERT JUDGES--
JANICE DICKINSON.
Janice: HEY.
BONJOUR, LADIES.
Tyra: AND WE HAVE
BEAU QUILLIAN.
BEAU QUILLIAN
IS THE FASHION EDITOR
AT "MARIE CLAIRE."
Beau: HI, LADIES.
Tyra: WE HAVE
KIMORA LEE SIMMONS,
WHO'S THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR
AND OWNER OF BABY PHAT FASHIONS,
WHO ALSO TOOK PARIS BY STORM
AT THE TENDER AGE OF 13.
AND, OF COURSE, EVERY WEEK
WE HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST JUDGE.
THIS WEEK IT IS MARILYN.
MARILYN HAS BEEN MY AGENT
AND KIMORA'S AGENT.
WE'LL BRING YOU IN ONE BY ONE
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES DELIBERATE,
AND THEN WE'LL DECIDE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
SHOULD BE ELIMINATED.
ELYSE, YOU'RE FIRST.
ELYSE, EARLIER TODAY
YOU COMPLETED YOUR TEST
WHEN MARILYN SENT YOU
ALL AROUND PARIS ON GO SEES.
Emma: HOW MANY OF THE GO SEES
DID YOU MANAGE TO DO TODAY?
Elyse: I DID ALL OF THEM.
Emma: OKAY, WELL DONE,
BECAUSE IT WAS HARD.
OUR CLIENTS DESCRIBED YOU
AS NICE, OPEN, FRIENDLY.
Tyra: WHOO-HOO, CHILD.
YOU ALSO HAD
A SEXY LINGERIE PHOTO SHOOT
WITH MICHEL HADDI.
HERE'S WHAT WE THOUGHT
WAS THE BEST SHOT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
Elyse: OH, I JUST THINK
THE POSE IS AWKWARD.
Janice: YOU HAVE TO STOP
PUTTING YOURSELF DOWN.
WE'RE A PANEL OF JUDGES.
WE'RE HERE TO JUDGE THE POSE.
SO I'M GONNA SPANK YOU
FOR DOING THAT.
I LOVE THE WAY YOU LOOK HERE.
Tyra: I HAVE TO DISAGREE
WITH JANICE.
I'M STILL LOOKING
AT MY PICTURES
AND A LOT OF THE TIMES,
I'M, LIKE, I DON'T LIKE THAT.
I COULDA DONE BETTER.
SO I LIKE THE FACT
THAT YOU WERE HONEST.
Marilyn: I LOVE IT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT POSED,
AS WE FOUND OUT,
SO IT'S VERY MODERN.
Tyra: UH, LET ME TELL YOU
WHAT THE PHOTOGRAPHER SAID.
HE SAID THAT YOU WERE THE BEST.
Janice: THERE YOU GO.
Marilyn: BONJOUR.
- Tyra: MERCI, ELYSE.
- Elyse: MERCI.
Tyra: SHANNON, VENEZ ICI.
Emma: SHE DID FOUR GO SEES.
HOW MANY OF THOSE FOUR
DID YOU MAKE?
Shannon: I MADE ALL FOUR.
Emma: WELL DONE.
OUR CLIENTS DESCRIBED YOU
AS BEAUTIFUL, BIG SMILE,
BUT MAYBE TOO OBVIOUS.
Tyra: TOO OBVIOUS
MEANS TOO PRETTY.
IN AMERICA, IT'S FINE TO BE
SAFE AND PRETTY AND LA,
BUT HERE YOU GOTTA...
JUST FREAK IT UP A LITTLE BIT.
Janice: GOTTA HAVE
THE EDGE, GIRL.
Tyra: SO YOU DID
A SEXY LINGERIE SHOOT,
AND HERE IS THE BEST SHOT.
Janice: YOU WERE ALL OVER HIM
LIKE A CHEAP SUIT HERE.
YOU GOT A THING FOR THIS BOY?
Shannon: WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVE TO GET TO KNOW HIM, BUT--
Tyra: I HEARD
HE'S A CHRISTIAN.
Janice: CHRISTIANS WITH ABS.
Tyra: (laughs)
Shannon: I LIKE TO FEEL
HIS PECS, SO...
Beau: IT STILL FEELS TO ME
LIKE YOU'RE, LIKE, INTO IT,
BUT YOU'RE STILL
A LITTLE BIT AFRAID
TO GO ALL THE WAY THERE.
Emma: OKAY, ADRIANNE, TODAY YOU
WENT ON FOUR GO AND SEES.
OUT OF THE FOUR GO SEES,
HOW MANY DID YOU MAKE?
Adrianne: I MADE THREE.
Emma: WHAT HAPPENED?
Adrianne: UM, I'VE NEVER BEEN
ON A SUBWAY IN MY LIFE.
AND THAT'S NO EXCUSE,
BUT IT WAS VERY HARD FOR ME.
Emma: NONE OF THE OTHER GIRLS
HAVE BEEN ON THE MéTRO,
AND SOME OF THEM MADE IT.
Tyra: I DO NOT
UNDERSTAND THAT.
I WAS ON TIME
LIKE MY LIFE DEPENDED ON IT.
Janice: YOU'RE RIGHT, TYRA.
THAT'S WHEN THE STRONG SURVIVE.
AND THE STRONG MAKE IT.
Emma: YOU WERE DESCRIBED
BY OUR CLIENTS AS STYLING BAD,
WOULD LOOK BETTER IN JEANS.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
Adrianne: LIKE, STYLING,
I AGREE.
IT WAS PROBABLY BAD,
I'M A REALLY BIG TOMBOY.
Tyra: IN PERSON TO ME,
I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE HIDING
WHO YOU ARE, AND CLIENTS WANT TO
SEE MORE AND WHAT THEY CAN DO.
DOES SHE HAVE GOOD SKIN?
IS SHE HIDING PIMPLES
BEHIND THAT FOREHEAD?
SO WHAT I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO DO RIGHT NOW
IS TAKE YOUR HEADBAND
AND JUST, LIKE, PUSH IT BACK.
Janice: GOOD CALL, TYRA.
THERE YOU GO.
Adrianne: I KINDA HAD
A FRO FROM EARLIER TODAY.
Tyra: THAT'S
SO MUCH BETTER, THOUGH.
Janice: YEAH, HELLO, BABY!
THERE YOU GO!
Tyra: OKAY.
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
Janice: SEMI-PORN.
Kimora: I DON'T REALLY LIKE
THAT LEG
OVER THE OUTSIDE OF HIS LEG.
Marilyn: IT'S ALL WRONG.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE TOTALLY HIDDEN,
THE WAY YOUR LEG IS OUT
IS TOTALLY WRONG FOR YOU.
Tyra: HELLO, KESSE.
Emma: OKAY, YOU WENT
ON FOUR GO SEES TODAY.
HOW MANY OUT OF THE FOUR
DID YOU MANAGE TO DO?
Kesse: I WENT TO THREE.
Emma: YOU ONLY WENT TO THREE?
- Kesse: YES.
- Emma: WHAT HAPPENED?
Kesse: I LOST TRACK OF TIME,
IT WAS MY OWN FAULT.
I SHOULDA BEEN
CHECKING ON TIME, SO...
Tyra: I USED TO HAVE
25 GO SEES IN ONE DAY,
ALL ON THE MéTRO,
AND I WOULD MAKE
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
Emma: OUR CLIENTS
DESCRIBED YOUR APPEARANCE
AS A GREAT SMILE, NICE SKIN
BUT NOT RIGHT FOR FASHION.
Kesse: I RESPECT
THEIR OPINION.
Tyra: HERE IS THE BEST SHOT
FROM THE SHOOT.
Beau: WERE YOU NERVOUS?
Kesse: YES, I WAS.
Janice: THAT MALE MODEL'S
ONE HAPPY CAMPER, HONEY.
- Tyra: YES, HE IS.
- Kesse: HE WAS...
HE WAS REALLY NICE.
HE WAS A GENTLEMAN.
Kimora: THE MODEL'S
NOT ALWAYS GONNA BE SO NICE.
THE MODEL COULD BE LEWD, CRUDE,
HE COULD SAY ANY OLD THING,
HE COULD GRAB YOUR BUTT,
HE COULD BE STINKY.
Janice: THE PHOTOGRAPH
DOESN'T WORK FOR ME
AS FAR AS THE HAIR AND THE HEAD.
I DON'T EVEN RECOGNI--
I DON'T SEE YOUR BEAUTIFUL FACE.
YOUR BODY'S OUTSTANDING,
THE FACE COULD BE
ANYBODY'S FACE,
AND YOU HAVE NO NECK.
Marilyn: I THINK YOU LOOK
A LITTLE BIT STIFF
IN THE PICTURE.
Janice: MAYBE HE WAS
A LITTLE STIFF.
Kesse: YEP.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, ROBIN,
HOW ARE YOU?
Robin: GOOD.
Emma: HOW MANY OF THE CASTINGS
DID YOU MANAGE TO DO?
Robin: I MADE ALL OF THEM.
Emma: NOW SOMEBODY TOLD ME
THAT YOU HAD
A LITTLE SECRET METHOD
OF HOW YOU MANAGED TO DO THEM.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TELL
THE JUDGES WHAT YOU DID?
Robin: A GENTLEMAN OPPOSITE...
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE TRACKS,
HE WAS, LIKE, "HELLO."
AND HE SAID, "HELP?"
AND I SAID, "HELP."
AND THEN HE CAME WITH ME
THE WHOLE DAY.
IN THE REAL WORLD,
THAT MIGHT NOT HAPPEN,
BUT IN ROBIN'S WORLD,
IT AIN'T NO TELLIN'
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
Beau: YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU CHEATED A LITTLE BIT,
GETTING THAT GUY TO HELP YOU?
Robin: OH, NO, SIR.
I DON'T FEEL THAT I CHEATED.
Marilyn: I WOULD NEVER ADVISE
A NEW, YOUNG MODEL
TO DO WHAT YOU DID TODAY.
Robin: YES, MA'AM.
Janice: YOU'RE LUCKY
YOU'RE ALIVE.
Emma: OUR CLIENTS SAID
THAT YOU COULD ONLY WORK
ON SPECIAL SHOOTINGS.
Robin: I GUESS THEY'RE JUST
GONNA HAVE TO CREATE
SOME MORE SPECIAL SHOOTS, THEN.
Tyra: YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
HERE'S THE PICTURE.
Janice: IT'S SUCH
AN ANGRY PHOTOGRAPH.
Robin: YEAH, I GUESS
WE DIDN'T HAVE A GOOD TIME.
Tyra: THANKS, ROBIN.
Robin: THANK YOU.
Tyra: ROBIN?
Janice: I DON'T KNOW
WHAT SHE'S DOING IN PARIS.
SHE'S TOO OLD.
AND SHE JUST CAN'T GET OVER
HER CHRISTIAN THING.
I'M SORRY,
SHE'S NOT WORKING FOR ME AT ALL.
Beau: BUT I'M ALWAYS
IMPRESSED BY ROBIN'S SPUNK.
YOU KNOW, I ALWAYS LIKE
TO SEE HER IN PERSON.
Marilyn: WELL, I DON'T HAVE
A MARKET HERE FOR ROBIN.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S NO MARKET
FOR PLUS SIZES IN FRANCE.
Tyra: I WAS NOT KEEN
ON THAT MAN HELPING HER
IN THE SUBWAY.
THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT TURNED ME OFF ABOUT THAT.
IT'S, LIKE,
USE YOUR BRAIN, GIRL.
- Janice: OUT.
- Beau: IN.
Tyra: ADRIANNE?
Kimora: I DON'T LIKE
THIS PICTURE OF ADRIANNE,
BUT I WAS PLEASANTLY SURPRISED
THAT SHE WAS SO SEXY.
Tyra: WHEN SHE
CAME IN TODAY, I FELT...
I WAS JUST NOT IMPRESSED.
I WAS, LIKE, YOU WENT TO GO SEE
GO SEES, YOU KNOW, LIKE THAT?
Marilyn: SHE NEEDS
TO LEARN A LOT, YOU KNOW.
SHE'S NOT READY.
- Janice: IN.
- Beau: OUT.
- Marilyn: OUT.
- Tyra: SHANNON?
Janice: SHE REALLY
THREW HERSELF
INTO THE ARMS OF THIS BOY.
I LIKE HER.
I THINK SHE'S IMPROVED WAY!
AND YOU KNOW,
IT'S NOT EASY BEING IN FRANCE.
Beau: YOU GUYS
ALSO GAVE SHANNON EXTENSIONS.
SHE'S NOT LOOKING AFTER THEM
VERY WELL.
THE HAIR IS LOOKING A LITTLE
BANGED-UP BARBIE DOLL TO ME.
Tyra: ELYSE?
Beau: LOOKS LIKE
SOMEONE DRESSED A SKINNY BOY UP.
Tyra: IN PARIS,
SHE IS THE STRONGEST,
IN MY OPINION.
AND I KNEW THAT PARIS
WOULD EMBRACE HER.
- Janice: IN.
- Marissa: IN.
Tyra: KESSE?
BEING A TOP MODEL
IS ALSO ABOUT DOING
A PERSONAL APPEARANCE
AND KNOCKIN' EVERYBODY DEAD.
I'M NOT SURE SHE CAN DO THAT.
Janice: AND FOR A GIRL
JUST NOT TO SHOW UP
FOR SOME AIMLESS REASON,
IT'S POINTS OFF FOR ME.
Kimora: I DON'T THINK SHE MAKES
THE MOST STUNNING PRESENTATION,
BUT SHE ALWAYS PHOTOGRAPHS
REALLY WELL.
Beau: I AM
PERSONALLY INVESTED IN KESSE,
AND I'D LIKE TO SEE
HOW FAR SHE CAN... SHE COULD GO.
Tyra: THERE ARE FIVE OF YOU
STANDING BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE
FOUR PICTURES IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE FOUR PICTURES
REPRESENT THE FOUR OF YOU
WHO WILL STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ELYSE.
YOU ARE THE ONE GIRL
THAT TOOK PARIS BY STORM.
CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
SHANNON.
WE ALL KNOW THAT YOU'RE
GORGEOUS IN AMERICA,
BUT I WANT THE WINNER
OF THIS COMPETITION
TO RULE THE WORLD.
BUT YOU WON'T RULE ANYWHERE
OUTSIDE OF OUR 50 STATES
BY HAVING SUCH A SAFE,
ALL-AMERICANA LOOK.
- CONGRATULATIONS.
- Shannon: THANKS.
Tyra: YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ROBIN.
TO ANYBODY
WALKING DOWN THE STREET,
YOUR BEAUTY IS UNDENIABLE.
YOU DON'T NEED
NO LITTLE FRENCH MAN
TELLING YOU HOW TO GET
TO YOUR CASTING.
USE THIS.
IT'S GOT YOU THIS FAR.
CONGRATULATIONS.
KESSE AND ADRIANNE,
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
Kesse: I'M ALWAYS NERVOUS,
THOUGH, BEFORE THEY ANNOUNCE
YOU KNOW,
WHO'S GONNA BE ELIMINATED.
SO I WAS, LIKE,
EXTREMELY NERVOUS NOW
SINCE, YOU KNOW, THERE'S NOT
VERY MANY PEOPLE HERE,
AND YOU KNOW, THE COMPETITION
IS JUST REALLY TIGHT.
Tyra: KESSE,
YOU ARE SO BEAUTIFUL,
AND YOU PHOTOGRAPH AMAZINGLY.
BUT I FEEL LIKE
THE FIRE INSIDE OF YOU,
YOUR DESIRE IS NOT COMING OUT.
I FEEL LIKE IT'S NOT
SHOWING THE WORLD
THAT YOU WANT THIS,
THAT YOU NEED THIS.
Adrianne: WHEN KESSE AND I
STOOD UP THERE,
I TOLD MYSELF I WAS GOING HOME.
Tyra: ADRIANNE,
WE HAVE TOLD YOU
TIME AND TIME AGAIN
ABOUT APPEARANCE,
ABOUT SHOWING YOUR STRENGTH,
ABOUT NOT HIDING
BEHIND YOUR HAIR.
AND WHAT I SAW TODAY,
I WAS VERY DISAPPOINTED.
YOU WERE COVERED UP,
YOUR HAIR WAS IN YOUR FACE.
IT WAS, LIKE, COME ON.
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
THE PERSON'S NAME
THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO THE MODELS' APARTMENT,
PACK THEIR BELONGINGS
AND RETURN TO YOUR HOMETOWN.
Tyra: ADRIANNE,
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING TO--
YOU'RE MAKING ME CRY--
TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU, KESSE.
WHEN KESSE WAS ELIMINATED,
ALL THE JUDGES WERE CRYING
THAT NIGHT, ACTUALLY.
FOR SOME REASON,
THAT ONE WAS A REALLY HARD ONE
FOR US TO LET GO.
Kesse: IT REALLY HASN'T FELT
LIKE A COMPETITION,
'CAUSE WE'VE JUST BEEN
HAVING SO MUCH FUN HANGING OUT
AND REALLY GETTIN' TO KNOW
EACH OTHER.
OUT OF THOUSANDS OF GIRLS,
I WAS IN THE TOP...
I'VE LASTED TILL THE TOP FIVE.
SO...
AND THEY'RE NOT MANY GIRLS
THAT CAN SAY THEY'VE DONE THAT,
YOU KNOW?
I TOLD ALL OF 'EM
THAT I LOVE 'EM AND GOOD LUCK
AND ALL THAT.
SO I REALLY MEANT THAT
FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART.
JUST LEAVIN' EVERYBODY
IS WHAT'S REALLY
HURTING ME THE MOST.
BUT I WAS REALLY
GETTIN' EMOTIONAL,
JUST THINKIN' ABOUT LEAVING
AND NOT REALLY ABOUT...
(cries)
STAY TUNED FOR SCENES FROM OUR
NEXT EPISODE
HERE'S WHAT'S COMING UP ON
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
YOU GUYS WANT TO GO SHOPPING?
WITH KESSE GONE THE RIFF BETWEEN
THE CHRISTIANS
AND THE PAGANS WIDENS
WHAT A BITCH
I DON'T GO SEE GRACE
SHE SUCKS
THE GIRLS NOT ONLY LEARN ABOUT
PARISIAN HAUTE COUTURE
THEY LEARN ABOUT PARISIAN MEN
AND A NUDE PHOTO SHOOT PUSHES
SOME GIRLS TO THEIR LIMITS
SO IF STAYIN RIGHT HERE I'M
TAKIN MIGHT MAKE ME
BE ELIMINATED, THEN THAT'S FINE